manny do you have any special memories
from the wild boys that stand out to you
my favorite stuff was the wow boys
uh stuff like all of the wildlife you
know assuming the alligators daytime and
nighttime
swimming with the sharks and also the
killer whales and the bears in alaska
swimming with the getting in the water i
had never got face-to-face with grizzly
always wanted to and of course i took
advantage of the water i got into the
water and the grizzly came up at me we
told the people out there the game and
fishing were studying bears they didn't
know what we were we said you know we're
just you know like biologists was like
over here to study the bears i got in
the water and they say no we're just
trying to confront the bears and get get
a situation
yeah the holy spirit an encounter um
some of my favorite stuff there's so
much of it though you know the snakes
were fun a lot of funny stuff too man
right a lot of the stuff was it wasn't
all animals lots of it was just
incredible
incredibly funny yeah is there anything
on that never made the i think what was
special was when we would actually find
animals in the wild in their natural
habitat because like grizzly bears for
example right so much of it was like
okay we're gonna pretend we're in
california we're gonna pretend we're in
africa but we're actually in in
california you know and and like or
maybe we are legitimately in some other
country but
we're gonna we're gonna
set up this shoot right here and they're
gonna bring an animal in a cage and then
let it out of the cage like sort of
makes it make it appear as if we
discovered the animal in in nature when
really we didn't there was a lot of just
filming out there they're so nice
remember that bear did both you and
chris got inside the sleeping bag
big bit uh chris in the butt okay yeah
yeah
chris had a uh a black bear on his list
of on his bite list he's a pretty good
one but
that's at the dangerous black bear will
go crazy on you
at any moment i'm gonna rip your head
off at any second you get between him
and his food
yeah that was the toughest thing for me
is that we spent so much time in zoos
and they had all these like transporting
animals to come and pretend as if they
were in the wild when they weren't like
i i didn't i didn't really like that but
like manny said man when we when we
found the grizzly bears in the wild you
know and the the killer everything that
we found in the wild like we found the
[ __ ] silverback gorillas in rwanda i
mean unbelievable what was that
experience like that wasn't there but
that was in a while yeah that doesn't
rip your head off
we had the [ __ ]
the silverback gorilla
babies in between us and the [ __ ] uh
and and the adults how big are they if
we were in between the babies and the
adults that then we would be so
dead yeah that was that was probably the
most incredible thing that that we
really like to pull on your arm it'll
come off okay he can rip your arm right
off one
one
that thing is incredibly powerful animal
no question about it what was so cool
about about any time that we shot with
manny you know how uh
how like jackass and wild boys they
would say these stunts are performed
under the supervision of professionals
right like manny counted as a
professional so as long as we had manny
with us no matter what the [ __ ] idea we
come up with we're allowed to do it
because it's under the supervision of
manny who's the professional what's your
profession
my profession is you know
i i self-educated i have a degree my
profession is i just have a reputation
i don't have any other stuff my
reputation isn't going to put you in the
most dangerous situation possibly
somehow make it a life out of it that's
that's what i'm gonna do the worst
situation i could put you the wild
animal that's that was the whole idea
and then you know hopefully everything
will come out good you know nobody gets
you know too hurt or something like that
right like when when manny like the
first day we ever filmed with manny and
knoxville says okay i want to get bit by
rattlesnake and manny says no that's not
you know like when manny says it's not
okay like he didn't
it's not [ __ ] okay and if manny says
it is okay that doesn't mean it's
[ __ ] okay
yeah did he ever tell you not to do
anything um i don't think i was ever i
mean i would always listen to manny if
manny said no don't do that it's called
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on amazon and type in stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on amazon and buy stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude